日本人じゃない人にを自供したとき
ふと気づいたら全身ユニクロ取ったとき日本語できるはずもない友人が記憶の中で急に
日本語で喋りだした時だからマジありえなくなる
トーンをそまえいつのまに洗濯物を変えて外に干した時待ち合わせ場所に10分前に
到着してごめん待ったアップ行った時はリバーしよう
綺麗に童時メールの内容よりその挨拶が長くなったと温泉に入る直前に思わず
タオルを頭に乗せたときスターバックスの店員がストレートでよろしいでしょうかと
日本人の恋人じゃなくて自分に聞いてきた時よと適切な英語が出てこないとき
蹄後輩マイア
後輩ってなんでいいんだった何か食べると聞かれて
納豆あるといった時エレンじゃなくてアルミンのコースプレイ書を作った時これ分かる
人手を上げて翻訳をタダでしなくなった時断りしますスーパーの職場んがパンの一種だ
と信じ始めたとき誰もいない家の玄関で
おおおおおおおおおおおお
ただいまと言った時リズじゃなくてほうじ茶を頼んだとキムという文字を忘れてそれを
また勉強して覚えるという過程を5回以上得た時そういえば京都には全然行ってないん
と呟いた時自慢げに
村上春樹読んだことある言わなくなった時か人が番号飯を食べ
布を晩御飯を食べながらテレビで見たとき自分の駅に電車が到着する1分前に自然と目
が覚めた時罪悪感一切覚えずに少年漫画を本屋さんで立ち読みした時
芝が美容院で平気で1万円以上費やしたとき自分が youtube で見る道
がの全てが入っていうことでで始まると気づいた時曇った日に日焼け止めを塗った時が
念のためにの会議をいつするかを決めるために会議を開いたとき無意識のうちに
ペットボトルつそのキャップをそれぞれのゴミ箱に捨てた時 nhk の理戦略を持っ
た時エンスーに合格
したとき
me